Facebook is suffering a major financial
blow after months of punishing headlines
about privacy and content concerns it
stock plunged up to 24 percent in
after-hours trading yesterday that was
wiping out as much as a hundred and
fifty billion dollars of the social
media Giants market value in under two
hours
this comes after Facebook announced
second quarter revenue missed Wall
Street expectations by around one
hundred and thirty million dollars and
growth and the number of active users is
slowing down CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson is Wired's
editor-in-chief good morning orin orin
is this the accumulation of essentially
missing those earnings and what has been
months of terrible news yet all of this
has come together into a very bad day
for Facebook they've lost they've have
much less a much lower operating margins
than they had before user growth is not
so good and it looks like the new
products they're rolling out are not as
profitable and so the market completely
freaked out with that number in context
the amount Facebook stock declined and
market cap is larger than the entire
size of McDonald's I mean that is a huge
drop and could end up being the largest
drop in history I saw one headline that
said Facebook gives a privacy over
profit is that a good way to put it that
is a good way to put it because part of
what's happening is it turns out it's
harder to make money when you put user
privacy first
so after GDP are after Facebook started
really solving the problems that it has
it turns out you can't make as much
money in the long run and that is partly
with the market to reactant and is that
why those apps have not been
blockbusters for them because they're
just not able to make that kind of money
or they're just not very good apps the
new things they've been rolling out so
what's happening with Facebook is that
the new stuff right like the stories
right which is Facebook's big priority
well you put in what you did during the
day and it disappears is much harder to
monetize than newsfeed and they're not
making as much money on Instagram even
though it's a hugely growing product as
they did on newsfeed and they're
spending more on security another thing
that hurts the bottom line right so the
good way to look at it is Facebook is
spending tons of money to fix all these
problems they're going to keep spending
this money which means they're going to
be less profitable that is the positive
way to look at it but the negative way
to look at it is this is just a terrible
time right there yeah but they have to
be doing the hula over there that
they've got Facebook and that they have
an Instagram that they have in store
Instagram and whatsapp
and messenger right I mean they have
four of the six biggest social platforms
owned by that company so they're going
to be okay in the long run
one thing that is incredibly interesting
about this is the stock is now lower
than it was January first employs some
of them are paid based on bonuses and
how the stock does over the course of
the year so if the stock continues to be
down that has a real effect on their
ability to retain people which is the
hardest thing for them all right Nick
Thompson thank you so much thank you